both vivec and RFK have said they'll
pardon Julian Assange or pardon Snowden
and that's resonating with an audience
even Elon Musk I think did a poll should
Assange and Snowden be pardoned I think
he did that last year I don't know the
exact results on how many what the
numbers were Rob if you've seen the poll
that uh musk did there you go 80 and a
half percent 3.3 million votes 80 and a
half percent said yes 19 and a half
percent said no do you think they should
pardon them and two do you think that's
really a big deal uh uh if one of those
candidates does that
I think it would have been I think it
was is incredibly disappointing to me
personally that Trump didn't
um he got way closer to pardoning
Snowden than Assange
um I thought it was a huge failure on
the part of trump not to do it the
reason he didn't do it and this is what
the second impeachment was about without
question like why were they impeaching a
president gaze away from leaving the
White House the reason was because
Republican senators were hanging over
Trump's head there were several things
they were fearful that he would do one
was declassify a bunch of old CIA files
including the JFK assassination the
other was pardoning Snowden Assange and
Mitch McConnell and Marco Rubio and a
bunch of them made very clear that if
Trump did any of that they were going to
vote to impeach him which would have
rendered him ineligible and or rather to
convict him and this that second
impeachment trial was about keeping
Trump under control on his way out I was
extremely involved in the effort to try
and get a part in for bold I knew how
close he was to Snowden I knew he wanted
to do it and I believe that's the reason
he didn't that doesn't exonerate Trump
for me but it um I think explains it but
the the I don't think there's a huge
this is not a huge issue for the
majority of Voters what symbolically
that would do though what is to say we
are not going to allow the secret part
of the government to continue to commit
crimes and to continue to hide the most
important things they're doing from the
public we're not supposed to have a part
of the government that operates in
secret we're the only people who get
punished are the ones who reveal the
crimes and the people who commit the
crimes are the ones who get shielded
these two cases are different Snowden
was somebody who actually worked inside
the government he had an oath to
maintain the secrecy of the documents he
ended up revealing Julian Assange is not
even an American citizen he has no
obligation to the US government of any
kind he didn't take any secrets he was
in the role of journalists he did
something the New York Times And The
Washington Post do every day which is he
got secrets from someone who worked
inside the government which is Chelsea
Manning and he published them and the
the fear of the Obama Administration
they wanted to prosecute Assange was
that how do we justify Prosecuting
Assange while we don't prosecute the
editors of the New York Times and the
guardian that worked with him to publish
exactly the same documents the case and
the problem with the Assange prosecution
aside from the fact that it's a huge
travesty in terms of press freedom is
that the United States has no ability to
go around the world and give its
lectures about press freedom in Russia
and Iran in North Korea and anywhere you
go to any of those countries an American
journalists and you say why is it that
you're imprisoning journalists who are
dissidents in your country who criticize
your government they will immediately
say are you kidding who are you to give
us that lecture you have arguably the
most Innovative and important journalist
of his generation sitting in a prison
cell going on a decade now if you count
the Asylum he needed from Ecuador who
who has done nothing wrong other than
reveal war crimes on the part of the
United States government so more
important than the personal outcome of
these two people in Snowden has an okay
life in Russia he's you know doing well
he has a uh an American Wife who was his
girlfriend from way before he became
Edward Snowden they have two small
children they have a beautiful family
he's doing well economically he can't
leave Russia but he's free within Russia
Assange is in a prison cell in a high
security prison cell
so beyond the kind of personal stake
which I care about a lot because they're
both my friends and Paul people I admire
a lot is the symbolic importance of
saying the U.S security state is not
going to continue to have the power to
destroy the lives of people who reveal
their crimes that really is ultimately
what it's about it would be an act of
incredible courage for a president to
stand up to the U.S Security State and
say we know you want these people
destroyed and we're going to Pardon them
and that's going to show that
transparency is now the new rule of how
you're going to function so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]